only cowards use
the media
against
a famous person who
they once loved they procreated with
nicki minaj has some choice words for
britney spears ex kevin fetterline
the rapper slams him on her queen radio
show for his public criticism of
brittany and attempting to expose her by
releasing videos with their two sons
using the person's fame
as this constant gotcha moment
and you think you're not gonna have
karma from it
you think it's okay
that woman is a sagittarius woman
she loves her kids more than life itself
last week kevin sat down for an
interview with itv explaining why he
posted clips of britney disciplining
their boys jayden james and sean preston
when they were pre-teens they
started sending me
videos and certain things that they were
like look i'm telling you that this is
happening have you lost your mind
i do care but i'm shocked as
with you and i don't know what to do and
i'm scared of you because you're weird
because you're going through puberty
kevin previously shared one video of the
pop star arguing with their eldest son
sean for allegedly not wearing shoes in
a store and ultimately taking away his
phone
i was in shock in the store when i
looked down and jaden how are you so
cool about that your brother being with
bear's big feet size 13 now well he's my
brother
and all the more exposed his feet your
blood in an ice cream shop in in alaska
weather
don't you think that's a little odd no
uh yeah i think your phone should be
gone
and then there's another one showing
britney setting some ground rules this
is my house if i want to come in here
and give you lotion for your face cause
it is coarse and all you tell me no it's
fine it's fine no it's not fine
you all better start respecting me are
we clear yeah you all need to start
treating me like a woman with worth
i am a woman
okay
be nice to me do you understand
yeah
at the time britney expressed her
disappointment in kevin for releasing
footage and shared her side of things in
a now deleted instagram post
as we all know raising teenage boys is
never easy for anyone but come on
there's being rude then there's being
hateful
adding they would visit me walk in the
door go straight to their room and lock
the door
the boys have decided that you know
they they're they're not seeing her
right now it's been a few months since
they've actually even seen her before
the interview kevin removed both videos
but explained why he posted them to
begin with quote i cannot sit back and
let my sons be accused in this way after
what they've been through as much as it
hurts us we decided as a family to post
these videos the boys took when they
were 11 and 12. this isn't even the
worst of it the lies have to stop
how dare you encourage this woman's
children
to be a part of your nonsense
they're kids they don't know that this
how detrimental this is but you know
as a mother herself to a one-year-old
baby boy it's clear why nicki is coming
to brit's defense i mean it's pretty
obvious right
yeah and nikki is no stranger to
speaking up for her former collaborator
back in march the queen of rap quickly
encouraged the pop princess when britt
said she wasn't the best dancer nikki
commented britney put your crown back on
and leave it there baby
so it only makes sense that nikki's not
taking any britney bashing from kevin
leave her
alone
[Music]
you